have you done uh
point correct conjecture with uh with
perlman that's too much that's too much
that's too much too much for me but it's
uh
it's it's interesting that you know and
going back to our discussion like the
the poincare paper was like published on
archive
and and it was not on a journal like the
three papers and
yeah what do you make of that i mean
he's such a fascinating human being
exactly i mentioned to you offline that
i'm going to russia he's somebody i'm
really try to interview him yeah well
so i definitely will interview him i
um and i believe i will i believe i can
i just don't know how to i know where
you live so
here okay my my uh my hope is my
conjecture is that
i if i just show up to the house and
look desperate enough
uh that uh or threatening now for some
combination of both
that like the only way to get rid of me
is to just get the thing done that's the
hope
it's actually interesting that he
mentioned that because i after i
um so a couple of weeks ago i was
searching for
like stuff about paramount paramount
online ended up on this
twitter account of like this guy that
claims to be
permanent perelman's assistant and
he's like he has been posting a bunch of
pictures like next to paramount you can
see like permanent in
in a library and he's like next to him
like taking a selfie or like furman
walking
on the street and like maybe you could
reach out to
this assistant then i'll send you i'll
send you this twitter account
so maybe you're on to something no but
but going back to like fairmont is super
interesting because
the fact that he published the the
proofs on archive is what was also like
a way for him to because he really
didn't like the scientific publishing
industry and the fact that you had to
pay to get uh
access to to articles and that was a
form of like protest
and that's why he published um those
papers there i mean i i think paramount
is just
a fascinating like character and for me
it's
this kind of ideal of a platonic ideal
of what a mathematician
should be you know it's it's someone
that is you know it's
just cares about deeply cares about
mathematics you know it
cares about fair attribution of of um
disregards money and um and and
like the fact that he published like on
archive was is a good example
what about the fields metal that he
turned down the fields metal what's
what's yeah what what do you make of
that yeah i mean
if you look at like the reasons why he
rejected the fields medal so after so
paramount did a post talk in the us
and when he came back to russia um
do you know how good his english is i
think it's very fairly good it's pretty
good i think it's really good
especially given lectures in american
union but i haven't been able to
listen to anything well certainly not
listen but i haven't been able to get
anybody because i know a lot of people
have been to those lectures
i'm not able to get a sense of like
yeah but how strong is the accent what
are we talking about here is this gonna
have to be in russian is going to have
to be in english it's fascinating but he
writes the papers in english so it's
true
like there's there's but there's so many
like such a fascinating character and
um there are a couple of examples like
him like at i think 28 or 29 he proved
like a really
famous conjecture called the sulk
conjecture i believe it was like in a
very short four-page proof of that
it was a really big breakthrough then he
went to princeton
to give a lecture on that and after the
lecture
the the chair of the math department at
princeton a guy called peter
sarnock went up to to department was
trying to recruit him
trying to offer him a position at
princeton and he was
and at some point he asked for
pearlman's resume
and fellman responded saying just gave a
lecture on like this
really tough problem why do you need my
resume like
i'm not gonna send you like i just
proved like my value
uh but uh but going back to the fields
metal like when
when perlman went to back to russia he
he arrived at a time where the the
salary of post docs was so
much off in regards to inflation that
they were not making any money like the
the people didn't even bother to pick up
the checks at the end of the month
because it was like ridiculous but
thankfully he had some money that he had
uh gained while he was doing his post
talk so he just concentrated on like
the point the the prank card conjecture
problem which he
when he when he took that um it took it
after
it was reframed by this mathematician
called richard hamilton
which posed the problem in a way that it
turned into this
super like math olympiad problem with
like perfect boundaries well-defined
and that was perfect for paramount to
attack and so he spent like seven years
working on that and then in 2002
he started publishing those papers on
archive
and people started jumping on that
reading those papers and there was like
a lot of
um excitement around that a couple of
years later there were two researchers i
believe was they were from harvard
that but took paramount pearlman's work
they send some of the edges and they
republish that
saying that you know based on pearlman's
work they were able to figure out
the the pronghorn conjecture and then
there was um at the time at the in the
international
um conference of of mathematics in 2000
2006 i believe that's when they were
going to give out the fields medal there
was a lot of debate like oh
who's who's like we should get the
credit for
solving this big problem and for
apparelment it
like it it felt really sad that people
were even considering that
he was not the person that solved that
and and
the claims that those like researchers
when they published
after paramount there were false claims
that they were the ones they just sanded
a couple of badges like parliament did
all the really hard work and so just
just the fact that they doubted that
paramount had done that
like was enough for him to say i'm not
i'm not interested in this prize
and that was one of the reasons why he
rejected the fields medal
it then you also rejected the clay prize
so
the ponca conjecture was one of the
millennium prizes there was a million
dollar
prize associated with that problem and
that has to have to do with the fact
that
for them to attribute that price i think
it had to be published on a journal
yes the proof and again paramount's
principles of
like interfered here and and he also
just didn't care about the money he's
like
um clay i think was a businessman and
he's like doesn't have to do anything
with with mathematics i don't care about
these like um
that's one of the reasons why you
rejected the yeah there's
it's hard to convert into words but at
mit
i'm distinctly aware
of the distinction between when i enter
a room there's a certain kind of music
to the way people talk when we're
talking about ideas
versus what that music sounds like when
we're talking
when it's like bickering in the space of
like
whether it's politics or funding
or egos it's a different sound to it
and i'm distinctly aware of the two
and i kind of sort of to me personally
happiness was just like swimming around
the one that like is the political stuff
or the money stuff and all that
uh or egos uh
and i think that's probably what
probably is as well like the moment he
senses there's any
as with the fields model like the moment
you start to have
any kind of drama around credit
assignment all those kinds of things
it's almost not that it's important who
gets the credit it's like the drama in
itself gets in the way of the
exploration of the ideas or the
fundamental
thing that makes science so damn
beautiful and and you can really see
that there's also a product of that
russian school
of like doing science and you can see
that
that that people were you know
during the cold war a lot of
mathematicians they were not making
any money they were doing math for the
sake of math
like for the intellectual pleasure of
like solving a difficult problem
yeah and you know even even if it was a
flawed system and there were a lot of
problems with with that
there's these they were able to to
actually achieve these
and uh there were a lot of and paramount
for me is the perfect
product of that he just cared about like
working on
tough problems he didn't care about
anything else it was just meth
you know pure math yeah there's a like
for
the broader audience i think another
example of that is
like professional sports versus olympics
especially in russia i've seen that
clear distinction
where because the state manages
so much of the olympic process in russia
as people know with the steroids yes yes
yes
but outside of steroids thing uh is like
the athlete can focus on
the pure artistry of the sport
like like not worry about the money not
just in the way they talk about it the
way they think about it the way they
define
excellence versus like in the
perhaps a bit of a capitalist system in
united states with
american football with baseball
basketball
so much of the discussion is about money
now of course at the end of the day it's
about excellence and artistry and all
that
but when the culture is so richly
grounded in discussions of money and uh
sort of this capitalistic like uh merch
and uh businesses and all those kinds of
things
it changes the nature of the activity
and it's in a way that's hard again to
describe in words but
when it's purely about the activity
itself
it's almost like you quiet down
all the noise enough to hear the signal
enough to hear the beauty
like whenever you're talking about the
money that's when
the marketing people come and the
business people the non-creators come
and they fill the room and there's
they create drama and they know how to
create the drama and the noise
as opposed to people who are truly
excellent at what they do the
the person in their arena right
like when you remove all the money and
you just let
that thing shine that's when true
excellence can
and can come out and that was of the
few things that worked with the
communist system the soviet union
to me at least as somebody who loves
sport and loves mathematics
and uh science that worked well
removing the money from the picture
you know not that i'm um not that i'm
saying poverty is good for science
there's some level in which not worrying
about money
is good for science it's a weird i'm not
exactly sure what to make of that
because capitalism works really
damn well yeah but it's um
it's tricky how to find that balance
you